what's going on guys this is Rob and I
told the guys over a quids I'd make a
video about this app that you have that
they or I'm sorry to quit has will you
get their like stickers and text
messages which is kind of interesting
they give you like like new point it's
all based on points and you get like I
guess coins and you get like new coins
every few hours like more coins they've
got these a little like these little
stickers that you throw in text messages
which is kind of cool let's grab like
ninja turtles I think I already have a
ninja turtle don't remember on my head I
just have to go to shop there we go um
and then we'll go with Michelangelo
because everybody knows Michelangelo's
the best one so we'll go with
Michelangelo and you you get this cool
unwrapping feature which is it's
actually kind of oh it's all of them
Michelangelo Donatello Raphael Leonardo
okay cool
alright so anyway um so you can go into
like your text messages and let's grab
together what do you mind Daniel it's
let's put up a picture of 80s bad guy
wears 80s bad guy like this this is
eighties bad guy right here also a
picture of 80s bad guy and then go we go
into what we want to quit and then we
grab like turtles all right slim
grab like one of those turtles and throw
them on there and now he's like 80s
Ninja Turtle
it's a terrible joke anyway I thought
you guys might dig it so you know I mean
it's in the App Store you can check it
out but anyway on to our video okay so
we got caught up with the new 52 Batman
right like we said we wanted to take our
DC days we want to cover new 52 Batman
Wonder Woman the movie came out we got
caught up with Wonder Woman
Sunday's is our Green Lantern day and we
got caught up with Green Lantern eye on
volume 1 mystery of the star sapphires
robbed man let me tell you some man on
the material no no Sinestro Corps war
god this story is so good if the story
is not it's absolutely you'd say this is
just a prelude to this is anything like
the main story this is just the prelude
and it's absolutely insane this is one
of those bonkers stories that I've ever
read in a good way in a good way it's
crazy in a good way it's crazy and it's
exciting in a good way let us get into
this let us cover that
so the cool thing about this is like
right off the bat we just get like the
motivations of Sinestro
right I mean Sinestro Corps you know the
yellow lanterns we get his motivations
right off the bat and that's the cool
thing about this because the first thing
we're told is that like Sinestro he
absolutely abhorred anything that does
not fall in line with what he considers
to be like structure and regimen and we
knew that right like we knew the hold
with the whole story of Sinestro with
him falling for the Green Lantern Corps
all of it was rooted in the fact that
where he was the greatest member of the
Green Lantern's you know the greatest of
their kind one of the most capable he
eventually succumbed to fear the reason
being because the fact that adds a Green
Lantern he believed that there needed to
be absolute order there needed to be
absolute structure it was always with
the smallest thing it's like the
quintessential example of Batman about
why he doesn't kill all you have to do
is justify at once and then he can
justify it a thousand times over that's
the position of Sinestro like he took
his ring and he said we're going to
institute absolute order and absolute
structure on his home planet and then in
turn tried to influence that across the
universe of course that led to the to
the guardians of the universe realizing
what it was that he was doing casting
him out of the Green Lantern Corps and
forcing him really to kind of run into
retreat eventually becoming a bad guy
and the most notable enemy of Hal Jordan
what this tells us is that initially
here I guess initially where he believed
that he was doing the right thing which
is why he was able to invoke willpower
the way he was he eventually realized
that it was fear you know it was fear of
the fact that things that he would
basically lose what it was that made him
who he was you know that he would lose
control over his sucker that he would a
ceccolini that he came to believe that
because of the fact that he was able to
institute the kind of order that he did
that came from the fact that people were
afraid of him they feared for and so
that's when they begin to realize that
fear is the best motivation for forcing
people to do the things that you want
them to do and that's the coolest thing
about this is because remember the
emotional structure exists out there as
this sort of disembodied thing that
basically is fed by all beings in
existence but it's only until recently
people learned how to tap into it the
guardians of the universe learned it but
in terms of other people it's this
little thing that happens every once in
a while you know for example Atrocitus
his whole family slaughtered his entire
sector is massacred by the by the
Manhunters and he in turn in his rage
and in his anger is able to tap into the
emotional spectrum of rage which in turn
allows him to create
Red Lantern Corps first we'll get into
that you know all that stuff later on
down the line but first Sinestro feeding
into his own fear you know really kind
of feeding into the concept of fear
itself he's interned able to tap into
the fear aspect of the emotional
spectrum and then effectively make
himself the first of the yellow lanterns
now this is so cool because remember
over the course of this whole idea of
the Sinestro Corps really what we're
told is that this little segment of
Sinestro basically forming his core is
basically a backstory it takes place in
the past what ended up happening is in
the modern day we know that right now at
least at the time the story's being told
that he sent rings out to basically grow
his Sinestro Corps army and one of these
rings had approached Batman and said you
have the power to instill great fear
welcome to the Sinestro Corps and then
ultimately cast it out once it realized
that he had used the Green Lantern ring
of Hal Jordan and that's why we covered
a lot of that stuff because those things
were so important and they sent a stage
for things that would come later on down
alive they were small moments there were
tiny little things that took place but
they all built to this greater thing and
that's how geoff johns wrote his Green
Lantern story if a thing would happen in
a panel or something would take place in
a page that would seem out of place and
totally unnecessary and then like five
or six stories later on down line the
entirety of a set of events hinders on
what happened in that one page and
that's why this is so cool man
limitations on just John's moon this god
knows how to write stories but it's why
it's so cool because remember you know
with the whole secret society as it was
formed by lex luthor after i guess
before and during the events of Infinite
Crisis Sinestro would serve as part of
that group now of course we also saw him
yeah basically serving alongside eobard
thawne so on and so forth and the reason
why that matters is because following
the Sinestro Corps ring approaching
perking batman and trying to bring
batman into its ranks batman basically
went told the rest of the Justice League
something's going on I was approached by
the equivalent of what looked like Hal
Jordans ring except it was yellow and it
said welcome to the Sinestro Corps how
do and of course intervenes because
investigating and that was the whole
idea of what it is the green I'm sorry
the Justice League is doing what he
Abarth on they're basically tracking
down all these leads on what the
Sinestro Corps is and what the Sinestro
Corps is about but no one has any
answers to that no one knows the answer
to this riddle now force again
transitioning over to Kyle Rayner keep
in mind with him we know he's a on at
this point on now explicitly what that
means will actually find out in this
story which is
what's so cool but all we really know is
that as the torchbearer he basically
holds a place beyond all the other Green
Lanterns he doesn't require a ring in
order to do the things that he does not
only that he's basically the sole person
that's going to be able to bring back
all of the Green Lantern's and the
guardians of the universe should they
all end up being destroyed now again why
he's able to do that
we'll get into that in this video but
him basically showing up coincides with
you a little bit of a conflict with a
couple of lanterns but the arrival of
this gree of this yellow lantern ring
which again says you know you do not
have the ability to instill great fear
you have not been chosen that basically
takes off and ends up going and finding
a suitable host now of course kyle
rayner
follows them along this path or at least
follows this ring to its most logical
conclusion but at this point we jump
over to the guardians of the universe
and so of course remember all this stuff
takes place after the events of Infinite
Crisis and so for those of you guys who
are just joining my channel who never
went through Infinite Crisis you'll find
the videos down in the description for a
more detailed explanation but the long
and short of it is that Infinite Crisis
served the purpose of restoring the
multiverse that was basically it
you know crisis on Infinite Earths saw
the multiverse being eliminated in its
entirety and was basically replaced what
a singular universe called new earth
Infinite Crisis saw the multiverse
brought back now this does invoke the
question of what happened with one of
the most notable members on the
multiverse which again we'll get into
that as we get to this story
but the fact remains that the way the
multiverse stands right now at least a
dozen to us by you know the guardians of
the universe is that it's really just
kind of standing on a knife's edge in
the sense that you have the main DC
universe and then on top of that or all
these different earths and so if the
main DC universe earth were to be
destroyed it would send a cascading
event it would basically wipe out the
multiverse but the other half of this is
remember we dealt with the return of
cyborg superman and all we really knew
was that the cyborg Superman had been
defeated at some point in time his mind
had basically been stuck inside the
source wall the wall that basically
keeps the entire DC universe contained
but from that point he basically
resurrected himself restore the
Manhunters again you'll find all this
stuff down to the description and then
in turn basically began creating an army
for himself now of course the Manhunter
served as the group that the guardians
of the universe used before they created
the Green Lantern Corps in the sense
that the Manhunters are basically just
robots remember the guardians of the
universe sat down and basically said
look if we're going to be the police
force so to speak of the universe we
need working
me too look around the universe and do
everything we can to keep it safe we
have to be impartial we cannot allow
ourselves to be governed by emotion and
so what we have to do is basically
separate ourselves from the entirety of
that ideology and so they basically
purge themselves of all emotion now what
this does is it basically says look with
them going through and creating the
Manhunters and and hunters basically
want to ride they rebelled demand
hunters were decommissioned
quote-unquote and in the Green Lantern
Corps was created in place of the
Manhunters EXO that's where the entirety
of the Green Lantern Corps comes from
now following the events of Infinite
Crisis when the multiverse was restored
and the mind of cyborg superman was
freed allowing him to basically recreate
his own body what this meant was at
cyborg superman had knowledge the fact
that the multiverse was back he had
knowledge of what was beyond the main DC
Universe and all the other universes
that were available now the reason why
this matters is because of the fact that
with him showing up this basically
begins the process of fulfilling the
prophecy of blackest night now the
prophecy of blackest night is amazing
and we're going to get into like the
blackest night story that's oh my god
madam Doo blackest night if God was
writing comic books right now is what it
would look like right now
blackest night is so good it's one of
the best stories that I've ever read
like in general absolutely mind-blowing
like oh dude again it gets so cool
anyway the whole idea here is that this
begins a process of fulfilling the
blackest line and we're literally told
what it was you know a face of metal and
flesh itself shall speak the secrets of
the 52 the 52 new universes you know
fear will rise will power will gather
basically meaning that the Sinestro
Corps will begin to rise to prominence
and the Green Lantern's will have to
respond and a war of light will unleash
the truth behind the power of the Ring
this is the entirety the entire basis
behind the prophecy of the blackest
night now again this is considered to be
forbidden knowledge this is something
they don't talk about it's the forbidden
fruit it's not something that the
guardians of the universe delve in now
of course the reason why this is
considered to be forbidden is because of
the fact that remember but I've been
sore have you been the Green Lantern
that passed his ring on to Hal Jordan
Abin Sur was told of the prophecy of the
blackest night by Atrocitus himself the
leader of the Red Lantern Court and so
because of all that again that stuff's
covered in my video on the secret origin
of Hal Jordan but because of that stuff
because of the fact that
right into the universe don't believe
it's real they basically consider it to
be nonsense they consider it to be an
instance of Atrocitus the Red Lantern
playing on the the idea of a band sewer
in the simple basically making him
scared and stripping him of his
willpower because remember a Green
Lantern can only really remain a Green
Lantern and use their ring to its full
capacity so long as they maintain
willpower and they don't allow
themselves to succumb to fear so the
guardians of the universe basically
looked at this prophecy and said these
are the ravings of a madman Atrocitus an
avid sewer fighting one another
Atrocitus at all there's a prophecy of
the blackest night hoping it would the
willpower of Adam sort which in turn
would lead to him being unable to defeat
Atrocitus that's basically how the
guardians of the university believed
this what we end up finding out is that
that's not true the prophecy of the
blackest night is very much true now
again one of the things that we also end
up dealing is you basically pick up with
Guy Gardner kind of racing off and
talking to Psilakis basically again this
sort of a voice for the decisions that
are made by the guardians of the
universe and of course you know Guy
Gardner basically says look
sinestro's back Sinestro has returned we
have to figure out what's going on with
what is what we're calling the Sinestro
Corps we don't really know what it is or
what it's about well in the middle of
this huge gathering with all these Green
Lantern's that have been brought
together by the guardians of the
universe suddenly a Sinestro Corps ring
appears and as it's going around hunting
for hosts it immediately realizes that
kara later is there now this is cool and
this is what this is so interesting when
it comes to the Green Lantern rings
they're very linear right like they
don't really have like a mind of their
own I mean they do to a degree but like
if a Green Lantern gets killed the ring
will automatically go out and seek a new
house it'll say you know Green Lantern
of sector you know three four one six or
something like that
deceased seeking a new host and it'll
just race off it'll find a new host and
it'll basically come across someone that
says you have great world power the
power to overcome great fear you have
been chosen welcome to the Green Lantern
Corps something along those lines and it
will whisk them off to OA to begin the
process of being trained now of course
at that point they can basically rebuke
the ring and say I do not want to be a
Green Lantern and the ring will choose
somebody else but in this instance the
Sinestro Corps ring what it's hunting
around immediately recognizes Kyle
Rayner is somebody unique among all of
the Green Lantern's it captures him and
it whisks him away to the antimatter
universe of the planet aport now again
one of the things that we need to talk
about here for us
and art accordions themselves this is
really Jeff John sort of drawing on a
lot of the old-school Green Lantern
stuff in the sense that even way back in
the day before Jeff jobs came along and
before he revamped a lot of these
origins really telling the backstory of
Sinestro what we knew was that where
Sinestro was the greatest of the Green
Lantern's somewhere along the line he
got his yellow lantern ring and what
happened were accordions are basically
the ones that fashioned the ring for him
this ring that basically fed on the
color yellow because remember back in
the day you know back before Jeff Jones
took over back in the 60s and 70s really
even the 80s and going into the 90s
there was no answer for why it is that
you know Green Lantern's are weak to the
color yellow
it's just they just are that's just
their weakness it's just the way it is
and so with Sinestro having a yellow
Lantern ring that allowed him to do
everything that a Green Lantern ring did
but basically defeat a Green Lantern
because the Green Lantern's couldn't
counter the color yellow in turn this
basically was establishes the idea that
the weaponers are poor these people in
the antimatter universe basically a
different universe from the main DC
Universe itself they basically fashioned
this ring for him now of course a lot of
this was included changed or eliminated
with regards to what it is a Jeff Jones
is doing now but the fact remains that
when Karl later is whisked off to the
planet core to this home base of where
it was that Sinestro was confined to
when he became a bad guy as a green
lantern and was held you know in a
prison of sorts by the guardians of the
universe he arrives to end up seeing
that all these cordials have been
totally eliminated and the reason why is
because Sinestro now has his army that
measures and the thousands there's
thousands of yellow lanterns everywhere
I mean he's on a planet surrounded by
yellow lanterns he's in what's probably
the worst situation that any green
lantern could be in and so because of
this Sinestro immediately grabs Karl
later and says we're taking you you are
going to be a host for parallax the
entity of fear the embodiment of fear
now this is the process in which Jeff
Jones begins moving away from the idea
of using metaphors or saying like you
know the embodiment of fear and
different things like that and actually
gives us physical ideas physical
constructs we're car later fights back
as best he can in the end he's just not
able to pull it off I mean the the
yellow impurity is basically gone I mean
that was an explanation that was given
really in Green Lantern
birth weather it was established that
parallax is the living embodiment of
fear in the entirety of the universe and
parallax had basically been defeated at
some point along the lawn and was
imprisoned in the Green Lantern's citral
power battery which is where all the
Green Lantern's get their power from the
reason for the yellow impurity simply
comes from the fact this parallax it was
inside the central power battery
eventually when you know how Jordan more
or less lost his mind when he went
through he be chaotic Laird himself to
be parallax all that kind of good stuff
and he was possessed by the parallax
entity the idea was that when he
destroyed the entirety of the Green
Lantern Corps because parallax had
bonded with Hal Jordan parallax was no
longer in a central power battery and
the reason why this matters is because
following the defeat of Hal Jordan and
Kyle Rayner basically going through and
resurrecting the entirety of the Green
Lantern Corps and the central power
battery this basically brought them back
without the yellow impurity without you
know parallax inside the central power
battery which is why they don't have a
weakness to the color yellow that's why
all that takes place so for some of you
guys hopefully the light bulbs going off
you just kind of like okay I understand
what's going on because that was
basically what was taking place it was
the idea of Geoff Johns sort of you know
fixing everything clearing everything up
and setting the stage for where we are
right now and so the crazy thing about
this is that while we have all these
different members of the Sinestro Corps
who have basically left the planet chord
and are assaulting or the homeworld of
the Green Lantern's in the middle of
this whole conflict suddenly some 30 or
40 Green Lantern rings just go whisking
by talking about how their existing
lanterns have all been killed and the
question is well who was it that did it
if somebody went through and killed all
these green lanterns in one shot
then who was it that pulled it off well
we end up transitioning over to the
science cells only to find out that
superboy-prime
is gone that's one of the coolest things
about this because remember in our
videos on Infinite Crisis we had talked
about how superboy-prime it basically
become a bad guy you know he had become
a villain and in doing so at the end of
the entire conflict he was basically
encased in a giant box of pure willpower
by the guardians of the universe and was
kept in stasis basically kept in the
presence of red radiation to keep him
from being able to use his powers and
keep him from being able to escape
that's how he's been held in prison this
entire time and so the idea seems to be
here that
essentially superboy-prime has been
given a yellow lantern ring he's become
part of the Sinestro Corps and that's
how he was able to escape so the cool
thing about this is we switch back over
to Sinestro that's one of the really
interesting things here because Sinestro
begins the process of talking about how
for him the entire popularity a really
the entire idea of the Sinestro Corps
it's predicated on the notion of
instilling fear and so what they're
doing is they're basically going around
and gathering all these different people
who basically have the power to instill
fear and virtually anybody across the
universe superboy-prime would be the the
swath that a cut through the superhero
community I mean remember during
Infinite Crisis Superboy prom took on
the Teen Titans young Justice and the
Justice League all at the same time I
mean that guy was stupid overpowered it
was crazy but the fear that he
engendered was enough that he caught the
attention of Sinestro and said that guy
is a must not only that with regards to
kala later being just you know being ion
and having the ability to basically
resurrect the Green Lantern court the
reason for why this is done is because
he's the host for the embodiment of
willpower the ion whale basically the
green lantern whale that's what he is
and that's how he's been able to pull
off what it is that he's been able to do
we didn't know this this is something
that was basically introduced to us
there's like a fresh piece of
information prior to this all we knew as
the guardians of the universe just said
you will be the one who will bring back
the Green Lantern Corps should we all
die and we didn't know why with regards
to him being the host for willpower what
this means is that now in this instance
that this is how he's able to resurrect
it he's literally the embodiment of
willpower itself but if he's the host
for pure willpower he can be the host
for anything else it's like taking the
battery out of something and putting a
new battery in and that's exactly what
Sinestro does Sinestro says all you need
to do is feel fear if I can strip you of
your willpower if I can pull this living
embodiment of willpower out of you then
you have nothing to feed on anymore you
have no way to keep your will going so
all I have to do is put something in its
place now at this point it's a roading
whatever willpower car waiter has left
and this is when semester begins a
process of feeding on all the terrible
experiences the Chi laners had over the
course of his life the fact that his
original girlfriend was killed the fact
that his mother died all these instances
are saying these are all your fault you
know and so again what this whole whole
idea is basically saying is pile
all the worst experiences you've ever
had in your life are your fault and by
making him experience all these things
it in turn begins the process of a
roading the willpower of Kyle Rayner
which ultimately makes him the perfect
host for parallax and that's what
happens parallax is let loose and the
living embodiment of fear across the
universe merges with Kyle Rayner making
him the new parallax and so what we end
up dealing is of course we have Kyle
Rayner basically asking the question
when do I get to kill folks and this is
it this is when Sinestro says you know
we'll start that soon in the meantime we
have to marshal our forces and so what
we learn is that in addition to
superboy-prime who looks amazing as a
yellow lantern by the way the
anti-monitor has been inducted into the
Sinestro Corps the anti-monitor was
resurrected with the return of the
multiverse remember the anti-monitor is
intrinsic to the multiverse itself if
it's there he's there it's just the way
it works
and so the anti-monitor has effectively
then inducted into the Sinestro Corps
due to the fact that with the anti
monitors desire to basically absorb and
obliterate all life in existence and
recreate everything in existence he
instills fear better than most anybody
else
there's also cyborg superman because of
the fact that he had still so much fear
as being one of the most notable
villains following the death of Superman
so again the ranks are being grown the
numbers are increasing and what this
does is lead into this insane conflict
that's really one of the greatest
stories ever told like in the history of
comic books but with that being said
guys we're going to go ahead and bring
this video to an end if you are new here
to come this explain place you guys
should the sub button to become part of
the robbed core if you guys enjoyed this
video make sure you drop a like next
Sunday or I guess this coming Sunday we
will pick up with Sinestro Corps war
part 1 so I'm really excited I'm really
high to bring that story to you guys and
yeah I will catch you all later peace
[Music]
you